and so part of our message to young
people is you know learn to master
yourself that is to be capable of a kind
of Liberty a profound kind of Liberty
that really has been we've lost sight of
in the modern world but that is
profoundly profoundly transformative and
also fulfilling
[Music]
hello everyone
today I'm speaking once again with
constitutional lawyer Missouri Senator
and best-selling author Josh Hawley we
discuss his new book manhood exploring
the structural significance of biblical
tradition within people's lives how
those enduring narratives Elevate us
above human defaults such as tyranny and
slavery why self-mastery is the
precondition for ordered Liberty why
young men have lapsed in education
industry and reproduction and what steps
might be available to help well
individuals and our society put itself
back in something like habitable order
looking forward to it
so I've been reading your book this
morning and it was sort of a strange
experience I would say because
strangely enough
or maybe not it's structured in a manner
that's almost identical to the book that
I'm writing at the moment
how about that yeah yeah so I'm writing
this book called we who wrestle with God
and
um I'm obviously animated by The Same
Spirit so to speak that you are because
the books parallel each other quite
remarkably and so I'm hoping my book
will be better but we'll see
I have no doubt I have no doubt well
yeah I don't know I don't know I'm you
know I have my doubts but um
uh we're we're aiming at the same thing
you know one of the things I've been
trying to struggle with too is you list
in your book a number of stories you're
using biblical stories primarily and
then a number of attributes that you
think constitute what might constitute
or what might comprise the central uh
aspect of masculinity you know so one of
the things I've been seeing in this as
I've been walking through the same
process is that the biblical Corpus
which is a library Aggregates a set of
illustrative stories
and then uses those stories to describe
a character to be emulated and then
makes the proposition that that
character to be emulated is the
manifestation of a single spirit
right so and that Spirit would be the
unity you're in your conceptualization
when you bring this down to earth so to
speak you talk about men being
husbands fathers Warriors Builders
priests and Kings right then you could
imagine that there's something behind
that that makes all of that
makes it possible for all of that to
become manifest and that's the
monotheistic spirit that the biblical
Corpus is attempting to
to characterize right and it looks to me
anthropologically it looks to me like
what's happened and I'm not going to
speak religiously but it looks to me
like what's happened is that
people in their various tribal groups
had dramatized patterns of adaptations
Central patterns of adaptation and then
characterize those Central patterns of
adaptation with the attributes of
something like a Transcendent deity and
then as the tribes aggregated themselves
each of those visions of transcendent
deity had to be integrated that actually
often
necessitated War there's actual war
between different tribes for what vision
is going to be dominant but there's
metaphysical battle too you know even
chair eliada the Romanian historian of
religions talked about the universal
battle between the Gods in heaven which
was an attempt at in the metaphysical
realm the pleuroma is what Jung called
it for these Concepts to go to war with
one another to and then arrange
themselves in a hierarchy
and so
anyways it's quite fascinating to see
that the same
underlying Drive
there's actually quite a few
similarities in our experience you know
you have Scandinavian ancestry you had a
child had uh arthritis as well and you
seem to be wrestling with many of the
same problems that have beset me for you
know forever so that was kind of it's
interesting to see that I also read the
guardian article Guardian review of your
book which was everything you'd expect
and hope for from the guardian
yeah hope for is is there I haven't read
it so you so you're one up on me there
but uh well you can just imagine it oh
I'm sure if they're praising you then
you've done something wrong that's my
usual motto yeah yeah well it's it's uh
that's the thing you know if if
there's to some degree if you're not
irritating the correct people you're
doing something wrong that's something
we could talk about too because one of
the dangers of the sort of Enterprise
we're involved in is the possibility of
you know increasing the degree of
polarization
rather than offering a positive Vision
which is what you're trying to do it's a
strange book for a politician to write
so let's start with that why'd you write
this book tell everybody a little bit
about the book and then tell me why you
were motivated to write it well I was
motivated to write it because I've got
two little boys at home I'm a father of
three and my two older are boys and then
I've got a baby girl who's two years old
but really Jordan it was thinking about
them they're ten and eight my boys and
uh my oldest is Elijah and my second is
Blaze and I write in the book about
Blaze Pascal so you begin to though I
don't draw this out on the book I don't
say it explicitly if you read the book
you begin to get a sense of why my boys
are named the way they're named and why
these ideas that I write about are so
significant to me they show up even in
my kids names and lives but thinking
about my boys and Elijah what's your
sorry the other boys Blaze for Blaze
Pascal yeah yeah yeah who I write about
in the book but it really it it was it
was thinking of the of my boys and my
obligation as a father to help them grow
into the men that they're capable of
being that set me thinking about the
book and then in my work representing
Missouri in the Senate you know I get to
meet so many men from around Missouri
from around the nation frankly and
seeing their struggles is seeing the the
the sense of alienation they're dealing
with the sense of depression the sense
of lack of purpose I have so many young
men tell me that that they feel like
they don't have any any vision for their
lives uh that they feel that they the
the media is against them as men that
their educational system is against them
as men so it was really trying to key
off of that and offer a a positive
affirmative vision for what men are for
and why it's good to be a man
the content I've created over the past
year represents some of my best to date
as I've undertaken additional extensive
exploration in today's most challenging
topics and experienced a nice increment
in production quality courtesy of daily
wire plus we all want you to benefit
from the knowledge gained throughout
this adventurous Journey I'm pleased to
let you know that for a limited time
you're invited to access all my content
with a seven day free trial at dailywire
plus this will provide you with full
access to my new In-Depth series on
marriage as well as guidance for
creating a Life vision and my series
exploring the book of Exodus you'll also
find there the complete library of all
my podcasts and lectures I have a
plethora of new content in development
that will be coming soon exclusively on
daily wire plus voices of reason and
resistance are few and far between these
strange days click on the link below if
you want to learn more and thank you for
watching and listening
thank you
[Music]
so the this idea you you covered a
couple of things there so that with your
sons for example
that you would like to encourage them to
be the men that they're capable of being
you know and I kind of Wonder I don't
know if this is a reasonable proposition
or not but it might be
the maternal
tendency
is I think to value
children for what they are
and the paternal tendency is to Value
children for what they could be and then
if you have that nicely balanced and I
mean the a man can value children for
who they are as well and a woman can
encourage what they could be but broadly
speaking the symbolic
proclivity the essential proclivity
seems to be that and I think that's
partly perhaps you tell me what you
think about this
women
have to bear the responsibility for
primary caregiving in early infancy in
particular first year
and there isn't a lot of
there's a an awful lot of taking care of
immediate needs in that first year like
that child's immediate needs are
Paramount because the child is so
utterly dependent born early as our
human infants are and in the state of
utter dependency and then
of course women have to wrestle with the
difficulty of
trans forming from that
state of hyper caregiving where needs
are predominant the needs of the moment
are predominant into facilitating
the independence of the child and that
seems to me to be where the paternal on
the patriarchal the father is
particularly Paramount to
to encourage maybe that's the primary
paternal role is to encourage
so
is that in keeping with the experience
that you had as a father and is that
does that make sense to you is there
anything you'd add to that no I that is
that has been my experience and I can
remember before I was a father and I
tell the story in the book when I was a
coach I was a young man I was 23 at the
time I was coaching a group of of rowers
uh kids a young high school team a crew
team and uh this was in the UK actually
and I remember I tell the story in the
book I had this moment where there was a
scene and during one of our training
sessions where I saw one of the rowers
encourage take a leadership role with
one of the younger ones and in that
split second I saw like a flash what
this this kid this you know he's
probably a junior at the time 17 years
old what he might be in the future I saw
a maturity in him I I saw
characteristics I had never seen before
and I just it struck me it's like oh wow
he could really become something he
could become a great leader a strong
leader he I saw a flash of the man he
could be and suddenly and seeing that I
realized my role my job as a coach to
him was to help encourage that and call
it forth and for me Jordan I tell that
story because that is a to me a parallel
fatherhood that helped me get ready for
what I think fatherhood is which is to
see that in my kids my boys and my girl
and to help call that forth to help call
forth what they could be and to be
willing to sacrifice myself and my
interests in order to see them develop
and grow
I um was fortunate enough to conduct a
seminar in Exodus in Miami and
um one of the stories
we evaluated in some depth was the story
of the burning bush
in that story which occurs in that
episode which occurs before Moses is a
leader he's wandering along minding his
own business intent on his own purposes
you might say and something captures his
interest and Glitters and gleams and
it's a phenomenon
phenomenon means it's from the Greek
famous thigh and feisty means to shine
forth and so something
grips his attention and makes itself
manifest and he turns off the path to
investigate it right he decides to
further investigate
and he does that of his own free choice
the story makes that quite clear so
something calls to him buddy it's him
that decides to go investigate it as he
gets closer to it he hears a voice and
it tells him that he's starting to tread
on sacred ground
and so he has to take off his shoes and
what that seems to mean is that if you
if something makes itself manifest to
you and you pursue it deeply you go
deeper and if you go deep enough you go
you enter sacred ground and that's by
definition right because what's deep and
what's sacred that's the same thing
technically it's the same idea and
everybody has a sense of depth compared
to shallowness let's say and so Moses
doesn't stop merely because he's on
sacred ground he continues to
investigate further
and he at some point as a consequence of
his engagement at least in part it's the
voice of God itself that speaks to him
and it speaks with the voice of being
and becoming God says something like I
am that I am or I am what I will be or I
have been what I will become it's the
voice of being and becoming and of
Eternity that speaks to him and what
that seems to mean is something like if
you pursue something that captures your
interest with sufficient intensity then
the voice of being itself will make
itself manifest to you and that's what
happens when people take something
seriously you know and that's when Moses
becomes a leader right because that's
when God tells him to go talk to the
Pharaoh it's not until that
transformation occurs and it's very much
akin to the story that you tell about
because it's it's a minor story in some
ways right that that experience you had
when you were coaching rowing you know
it's it's a mundane story it's the sort
of thing in some way that could happen
to anyone but you said it struck you and
it also shaped the way that you
conceptualized fatherhood and that you
could see the potential in this young
man all that happened at the same time
yes yes all that have happened at the
same time and it was a significant
moment it was a mundane setting I
suppose much like a bush in the
wilderness right but it was a
significant moment in that it it really
shaped my sense of at the time as a 23
year old you know coaching a group of
kids what is it I'm supposed to be doing
with these kids and it just like a flash
it I I thought I'm supposed to be
helping them not only become better
athletes of course but to become the men
that they might be and there was a sense
of sort of responsibility that came with
that having seen who these kids might be
having seen what they might be having
seen their potential I was obligated to
help call that fourth and I think as a
father that's absolutely what we do as
fathers and that's the responsibility we
have as fathers well you know it's
interesting one of the things that
has been
phenomenon
that's been continual in the lectures
that I've been doing around the world is
the proclivity of the audience to fall
absolutely silent when I discussed the
relationship between responsibility
and meaning and I'm suggesting to the
people that I'm talking to that
one of the things that you need in life
is a meaning that will sustain you
through suffering that's almost like a
definition of a deep meaning right it'll
sustain you through suffering and I
offer the possibility that the place you
find out is in responsibility this is
something conservatives have been bad at
they're bad at it because they Hector
and lecture young people about what they
should do as if it's a kind of detached
morality you should be good because
being good is the right thing you know
it's like an abstract call to duty and
there's something in that I don't want
to be cynical about that but that's not
the core issue the core issue I think is
the fact that
in that adoption of responsibility you
find the deepest meaning and that's
really true on the mentoring front you
know like my graduate supervisor for
example his name was it's Robert peel
he's still alive I still work with him
and I went to his first shift which was
a celebration of his academic career
when he retired and he had about 40
people there they were students mostly
that he had mentored and there's an
extremely positive event and the reason
for that was because Bob
was a very very good Mentor he gave
credit where credit was due he tried to
develop people and he didn't take
he he distributed his ideas widely and
was generous with them and he taught
people how to be independent and how to
conduct themselves as independent
researchers and he helped them develop
their lives and their careers as
scientists and academics and clinicians
and he was really good at it and he
really liked doing it that's the that's
the crucial issue here is that there's a
meaningfulness in mentorship that
justifies the sacrifice because you
might say well why bother developing
other people and part of the answer to
that this isn't just a hedonistic answer
is that well there isn't anything that's
more delightful and meaningful to do
than that as far as I can tell I mean
maybe my relationship with my wife in
some ways would triumph over that and
some of the intellectual interests that
I've pursued but other than that that
pleasure in in aiding the best in other
people to come forward I don't think
there is a deeper pleasure than that
though I agree with you I don't think
there is either and just to your point
about the power of responsibility and
why it's sure we want to call people to
duty yeah of course but
the power of responsibility it is the
most transformative thing in your life I
believe that's been my experience and my
observation if you want to exercise
influence of life I think every man
wants to be influential and wants to
leave a legacy and I become convinced
over the years that if you want to have
influence if you want to leave a legacy
take on responsibility and pour into
other people I mean you talk about
transforming yourself yes but also
transforming the lives of others and
ultimately transforming the world around
you that is done through shouldering
responsibility and sacrifice living in a
sacrificial way that empowers and
enables others it's the ultimate Legacy
and I think there's something in that
for men that they want to hear they want
to be called to that
yeah well that sacrificial element is
extremely interesting and this
I suppose brings us back to the biblical
motifs that proper work is sacrificing
and that's a definition again is that if
you're working what you're doing is
sacrificing and you might say well what
do you mean sacrificing and the answer
is well you're sacrificing the
hedonistic whims of the moment
for the medium to long term that's
literally what you're doing you're well
you could say and you can think about
that in two ways I think this is very
useful as
number one like if you just do what you
want right now all the time one of the
problems with that is you're going to
get yourself in trouble and everyone
knows that this is why two-year-olds
can't really live on their own because
they're whim predicated and they will do
what they want to do write bloody well
now with no thought whatsoever for the
iterating consequences of that into the
future and so because people are
self-conscious and can see the future we
have to bind our actions in the present
in relationship to our future selves so
you have to act now so you don't hurt
you tomorrow and you next week and you
next month and you in a year and five
years and ten years and
maybe even when you retire and that's
actually a community
right it's a community of potential
cells that extends across time and I
don't think there's any difference
between that and serving the community
as a whole I think that's the same ethos
and so the sacrifice would be joint it's
this you sacrifice the whims of the
moment so that's delayed gratification
and maybe a definition of maturity you
sacrifice that because it's a better
medium to long term
contractor Covenant with yourself but at
the same time that applies to everyone
else because there's no difference
between me serving who I'm going to be
when I'm 75 and me serving other people
and so that that ethos unites and then
the the payoff for that is that I think
the payoff for that emotionally is the
sense of meaning and purpose that
suffuses that Enterprise and that's not
exactly a hedonic it's not a hedonic
pleasure right it's not say it's not
infantile satiation it's a deeper and
more comprehensive
it's a deeper and more comprehensive
motive
experience and it's worth sacrificing
for and it's real
yes and there's a there's a a connection
here I think also with liberty and
freedom and this is something that I
talk about in the book you know that to
in order to experience true Liberty
self-discipline self-mastery and yeah
self-sacrifice is necessary and of
course this is a tradition that goes all
the way back to the Greeks and the
Romans it's certainly there in the Bible
that says as we learn to discipline our
passions in the moment as we learn to
discipline our whims in the moment as we
learn to master ourselves we become
possible of a kind of Liberty where we
we can see our true interest in the long
term we can see the interests of those
around us who we serve and we can become
self-governors literally and then
participate in self-government and I
think that the modern left and probably
the modern right has completely lost
sight of that whole tradition and so
part of our message to young people is
you know learn to master yourself that
is to be capable of a kind of Liberty a
profound kind of Liberty
that really has been we've lost sight of
in the modern world but that is
profoundly profoundly transformative and
also fulfilling
you know most young men understand
that most young men are interested at
least to some degree in in games and
sports and if it's not physical Sports
it at least it's video games and uh
thing about video games is and games in
general is that they are ordered they're
forms of ordered Liberty they're not
chaotic because they have rules and if
you're going to be good at the game
first of all if you're not good at the
game or if you're not interested in the
game then why the hell play it so if
you're going to play the game it's
because you want to be good at it and
you want to play it and so you've
already bought in and if you're going to
do that then you have to follow you have
to abide by the rules and hopefully you
can do that skillfully and that scales
like it's not just true
of games per se it should be true of
your life you know when when God makes
himself manifest to Moses and calls him
to be a leader what he tells him to tell
the Pharaoh is something very specific
he says tell the pharaoh to let my
people go
so that they may worship me now the
civil rights leaders almost always
stress the first part of that statement
but they don't pull in the second part
and that's a big mistake because the
second part speaks of ordered Liberty
and disordered Liberty that's the desert
right that's where the Israelites end up
after they flee the tyranny
it's a chaotic realm they can go
anywhere and do anything there's no up
or down there's no direction there's no
leadership and that's so terrible that
they start to Pine for the tyranny right
while they also start to worship false
Idols which is definitely a story for
our time but they also start to Pine for
that tyranny and you know you're making
the case and you make it repeatedly in
the book that self-mastery is the
precondition for ordered Liberty and and
if if the conservatives and you are
doing this in your book if the
conservatives could get the notion that
the deepest meaning in life is to be
found in the Mastery of that ordered
Liberty then they have a message they
can tell to young men in particular and
yes yes yeah yeah so so now you now you
you're writing a book here that's not
primarily political no and yet you're
you're operating in the political realm
and so how do you experience the tension
between those two and and how do you
believe that we could bridge the gap
between the
the motivation let's say and the
narrative
the sacred fundamentally and the
political and how do you manage to do
that in your own life or do you and how
do you fall short
good great question I I think that one
of the reasons I wrote the book and
you're right it's not it's really not a
political book at all but my my
conviction is is that we have in our
culture and particularly on the left but
also some on the right we've lost sense
of and we've lost touch with our most
foundational moral intuitions and moral
foundations and that's why I go back to
the Bible and the book you know and I
make the case early on that the the
biblical tradition is in many ways the
foundational story and Narrative of the
entire Western tradition certainly the
American tradition so I think that we
live in a world and this is true for
young men in particular where there's no
story there's no narrative you know what
is it that it means to be a man there's
no narrative there what is it that I'm
supposed to do with my life there's no
narrative so I think we've got to go
back to and recover those narratives and
that's why I try to recover some of the
symbolism of Genesis you know what is it
the man is called to do it's called to
make the Wilderness into a garden right
to expand that Garden God makes a garden
the rest of the world is Wilderness
what's Adam there the garden to do he's
there to expand the garden Into the
Wilderness there's something profound
there about what it means to be a man
and you talk about a high calling
because really what God does in Genesis
is he gives his work to Adam he says all
right I've created the world now I've
created a garden in the midst of the
Wilderness now Adam you follow my
example you take this Garden you expand
it you use your responsibility you use
your Authority you use your strength and
you expand it into all the world and my
conviction is men need to hear that
story the same is the Bible's making a
point with that of course that that is
there's an archetype there an archetypal
pattern of what it is men are supposed
to do to expand the garden to make or to
bring order from chaos to make Beauty
where there's chaos and so I think
telling those stories is critical then
to recovering in our culture some sense
of order and purpose and meaning and
then we've got to give in our politics
the key is how do we give that voice you
know how do we then cash that out into
policy and you know we talk about that
if you want I've got all kinds of ideas
about that but I think there's
tremendous value personally and
culturally in recovering these
foundational stories about what it means
to be a man what it means to be a woman
and what we're here to do
I like knowing exactly where my meat
comes from and with moink I know it's
coming from small Family Farms all
across the country Mike delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door Mike lets you
choose the meat delivered in every box
select an existing box or create your
own set your delivery Cadence and enjoy
delicious meat you can cancel anytime
but you won't want to if you're not sure
where to start check out their standard
box it comes with a little bit of
everything chicken ribeye burgers and
steak moink is all about supporting the
Family Farm think about it this way two
percent of Americans are farmers but 100
of Americans eat we need to show our
support for the families that keep us
well fed after receiving my first white
box I was floored the salmon and chicken
are both fantastic and the steak might
be the best I've ever had and keep in
mind I cooked it myself with a freezer
full of moink products I can without a
doubt say it is a fantastic deal on a
ton of delicious and well-produced
products you won't be disappointed and
you can rest assured all of Mike's Meat
comes from wholesome American farmers so
keep American farming Going Strong by
signing up at moinkbox.com jbp right now
in Dr Peterson's listeners can get free
bacon in your first box and let me say
it's the best bacon you'll ever taste I
re-upped my subscription because I ran
out too fast Mo ink box.com jbp that's
moinkbox.com jbp
[Music]
so I want to go in two directions with
that so
the first direction we might say is
there's there's only three situations
that we can find ourselves in we can we
can find ourselves United
psychologically and socially socially by
an overarching narrative or we can let
that narrative fragment which means that
we'll be tribal once again both socially
and psychologically and and the cost of
that fragmented tribalism is anxiety and
hopelessness and social conflict that's
the chaotic state of nature anxiety
hopelessness and social conflict okay
now if if you see that and I think the
evidence for that by the way is
incontrovertible if you see that a
question arises which is well what might
the central unified narrative be now
what what's happened on the left is the
central Nerf unifying narrative although
the leftists often claim there isn't one
what they've replaced it with at least
implicitly and often explicitly is a
narrative of power
and this is and this is something you
touch on in your book in your book too
with regards to the ideas of toxic
masculinity and so the accusation is
that all social relationships are
structured as a consequence of
domination and oppression and
victimization and that's true for
marriage
and it's true for family traditional
family and it's true for economic
organizations and political
organizations it's all about power and
so
if you accept that you can see very
quickly why The Narrative of toxic
masculinity might have Arisen and been
accepted because if you believe and
maybe you believe this because you've
never had any experience with a good man
even once in your life this is often the
case you know like I talked to Naomi
wolf recently who's been a very powerful
voice on the leftist front and you know
she had some bloody brutal experiences
with men she was raped when she was 11.
and that didn't help and then when she
went to University instead of being
mentored she was hit upon and in a way
that
you know Rose reminiscent of what
happened to her when she was early so
then she didn't get mentored and her
whole conception of masculinity which I
believe is rather fragmented is
predicated on her genuine experience of
being exploited and hurt and then we get
a cycle right you can see a cycle
developing there and so
your claim is that the narrative that's
running through the biblical Corpus is a
good unifying narrative it's the right
unifying narrative now I just talked
with Stephen Fry a couple of days ago
and Stephen is very interested in
mythology and although he's
I say he's he likes to shake his fist at
God and he has his reasons and he isn't
convinced at all that there's a reason
that the biblical narrative code per se
should be set up as primary like I
happen to disagree with him because I I
think it should be but it isn't obvious
to me why it should be you know and I've
done a fair bit of delving into
mythologies and so forth from from all
over the world and found lots of useful
information in them so how how would you
justify how do you think it's reasonable
to justify your assumption that
you know it's back to the Bible to use a
you know an old Evangelical phrase why
do you think that makes sense and why do
you think it's not just like an
extension of patriarchal neocolonialism
or something of that sort
yeah two answers the first one is
historical and the more surface answer
and that is for American history this is
a purely historical matter no text has
been more influential no set of ideas
has been more profound in shaping our
system of government our basic moral
intuitions then the Bible and the
biblical tradition so in a sense the
first answer is it's our tradition our
most fundamental moral intuitions are
grounded in that tradition and I I go
further I'd say that's actually true of
the entire Western tradition you know
Leo Strauss as you know had this great
saying that it was a the interplay of
Athens and Jerusalem that really forms
the west and there's something to that
I'm not astrassian but there's some
there's something to that but the
biblical tradition the Jerusalem
tradition is so foundational as a
historical cultural matter number one
number two I would say as a as a
Christian a practicing Christian myself
I think that it that it's power
Direction the fact that it's
fundamentally true I mean that there's
there's a reason why the stories of of
the Bible both the Old Testament and the
Christian New Testament are so
profoundly effective and transformative
in different cultures over time and
certainly in hours I would argue and
that's because they touch on something
they're true in fact I would argue they
are they are the truth capital T so you
know whether you accept that second
claim or not I I certainly think that
the cultural element it's just hard to
deny that American culture is organized
around and and derives its you know what
what Charles Taylor would have called
the moral sources right the moral
sources of our culture the Bible is is
the moral source so that those would be
my arguments okay okay so let's take
let's let's take let's take each of
those in turn let's start with a
historical argument and so one of the
things that
strikes me as
problematic let's say with projects like
the 1619 project or the leftist
insistence in the United States that
America per se was founded on let's say
slavery and oppression
the reason it really bothers me is
because I think it's an anti-truth I
don't think it's just a lie because a
lie is sort of like a deviation from the
truth but an anti-truth is something
that's exactly the opposite of what's
true and this is how I look at it so the
first question might be well is slavery
a universal human proclivity or not and
the answer to me to that as far as I can
tell and I've done some research into
the topic is yes it's the default
mode of operation for human cultures has
been slavery and that might be a
consequence of our proclivity to engage
in war because my suspicions are that
the institution of slavery arose as a
consequence of capturing enemy
combatants deciding not to kill them
which would be the simple thing to do
and then use utilizing them and also
feeling justified in doing that because
well after all they were trying to kill
you or there was a reason you were at
War
and so we could say well slavery is the
default condition for social
organization
so then
what emerges out of that is a kind of
miracle and the Miracle to me is that
any society ever decided that that was a
bad idea and as far as I can tell the
society that decided that most
particularly and explicitly was Great
Britain and that was particularly Wilbur
Force and he was an Evangelical
Christian and the reason that he opposed
slavery 100 the reason that he opposed
slavery was because he was steeped in
the biblical tradition
and so and then the Brits fought slavery
on the high seas for 175 years and
basically eradicated it as at least a
morally acceptable
um Enterprise and the American tradition
comes out of that tradition and even if
the U.S like other cultures is
contaminated by the desire for power
it's the
anti-slavery ethos that's actually
Central to the entire project and so
when the radical types are making the
claim that Western culture is
essentially slave holding in its Essence
as far as I can tell they are opposing
the only strain of culture which also
wasn't Western by the way because it's
not like the Bible is a western book
exactly it's not European it's an import
and so
they're opposing the only strain of
thought that's ever existed that made in
both a powerful implicit and explicit
anti-slavery case and so that seems to
be entirely counterproductive if they
actually care about slavery and then one
one more Twist on that historically
speaking well I don't think that it's
debatable
you the enlightenment types like Stephen
Pinker would debate this I I think but I
think he's wrong I think all the
Societies in the world that are free
and productive and generous and those
would be the societies that people would
flee to if they had their choice all of
those are offshoots of the biblical
tradition every single one of them
and I can't see that
I can't see that as chance and I also
think the same thing about literacy is
that without the biblical tradition it
was the biblical tradition and the
invention of the printing press that
brought literacy to the world and it
needed both of those the Chinese had the
printing press but they didn't have that
Evangelical fervor to elect to
to uh to bring everyone up to the
Pinnacle of self governance and
self-realization the Bloody Brits they
wanted to do that even to their colonies
you know and Wilberforce talked a lot
about that too is that it was the
obligation of the Brits as as the
colonial administrators say to inculcate
in the people who they had colonized
the spirit of Independence and freedom
that would enable them to be
self-governing citizens and I also think
that the British Empire managed that to
a great degree you know there's plenty
of terrible mess and catastrophe along
the way but the U.S and Canada are both
and Australia and New Zealand these are
great countries
and you can say the same about many of
the other commonwealth countries
including India they're beneficiaries of
that tradition and it's English but it's
also more more deeply biblical so I
think you can make an extremely strong
historical case for this I don't know
what the contrary case would be it's got
to be the enlightenment idea right that
it was the Enlightenment that produced
now let's talk about that because you
talk about the French revolutionaries
yes and okay so do you want to just
outline that part of your book and your
thoughts on on on the the French
rational revolutionaries yeah absolutely
but first can I disagree with you by
making by restating wilberforce's
argument because I think you've made a
profound point there Wilbur Force's
argument from the Bible from the
biblical tradition was I think twofold
number one it is the idea in the Old
Testament and you mentioned it when you
talked about Moses God says to Moses
tell Pharaoh let my people go why so
that they can worship me there is an
equality there that is implied there's
only one king right I mean the message
of the Old Testament is there's one God
Only One Sovereign everyone else serves
him but because of that everyone else is
equal you know you don't have this
hierarchy of gods and therefore
hierarchy of humans in the Old Testament
God eventually does give the Israelites
a king but that but that is a concession
to them and of course in the Old
Testament God says they've rejected me
from being King they want a king over
themselves and he warns them about the
king he says you're not gonna like this
King the king's gonna oppress you the
king's not going to treat you as equals
so you have the Old Testament tradition
which is very strongly God is Sovereign
and he calls all humans are equal before
him number one number two is the
Christian tradition which of course
extends that and the Christian tradition
is that in Christ there is no slave or
free Paul says that explicitly there is
Saint Paul there is no male or female
there is no Jew nor Gentile all are
equal in Christ and the spirit of God is
poured out on all people those are
profoundly revolutionary ideas
revolutionary it is and Wilberforce got
that and extended that applied it if you
like in his own time but to your point
about why why the tradition of the Bible
is a revolutionary tradition everywhere
it goes every culture it touches whether
we're talking about Ancient Rome or
Britain or America it always cuts
against what I think you correctly
identified as the natural human tendency
to organize culture around the elite who
have the power and everybody else who
are basically slaves and the biblical
tradition Cuts against that everywhere
it's applied so there's something very
powerful and profound about that now the
French Revolution here's what I said
Babel that's the Tower of Babel Proclaim
yes by the way right correct the
erection of Babylon as uh a profane
alternative to proper sovereignty and
the proper sovereignty it's part of what
the Bible is attempting to do is
actually to Define what constitutes the
proper sovereignty and it isn't the king
it's not the it's not the Earthly ruler
it's something Transcendent and eternal
what what and that would be the
principle of sovereignty itself it's
something like that whatever that
happens to be and you're trying to
outline that in your book yes can I just
ask actually on this point because this
is an interesting point with with
ancient mythology and the contrast with
the Bible and and this is this is your
area much more than mine but in in the
Bible we don't have a hierarchy of gods
we have one God we don't have a a a a a
a a myth in which you know the gods
order themselves you've got one God
who's in charge all the other gods are
servants are slaves to him and then that
replicates itself in the human realm
right you see in the other mythologies
you have the hierarchy of the Gods and
then that hierarchy replicates itself
among the humans right and so it's
natural in a sense to think of oh well
if there's a hierarchy of gods and
there's one lead God or several and then
there are slave Gods if you like the
same thing would be true on human
cultures the Bible different picture
altogether no there's one God the humans
are not his slaves he does never treats
them as slaves he treats them as
partners who are called in to cooperate
with him and in some sense called into
his Divine Life with them very different
picture and I just wonder
back to the idea of why is the biblical
tradition why does it tend to produce
equality self-government Liberty these
other Traditions don't maybe that's part
of it maybe it's this fundamental
difference in how they picture the
universe so anyway
well it's also not just the New
Testament that stresses that too because
one of the miraculous elements of the
earliest biblical writings in in Genesis
1 is the insistence this is a very
strange insistence that first of all
whatever God is is equivalent to the
spirit that calls the habitable order
that is good out of chaos and potential
which is I think what you're doing when
you're mentoring for example it's an
example of that but that that Spirit
characterizes men and women alike and
equally yes and that's yes and this is
another thing you know I've talked to
feminists who say well you know the Old
Testament particular is a patriarchal
document and I think you're completely
out of your mind it's so
anti-patriarchal that it really is a
kind of Miracle because the notion that
there was a fundamental equality between
men and women and that that was grounded
in in equal access or equal
characterization by the Divine there
isn't a more radical claim than that on
the on the gender or sex front and the
the notion in the in the New Testament
that each person is a locus of divinity
and intrinsic worth is a reflection of
that initial statement and that that's
established it's like the fifth thing
that happens in the biblical Corpus it's
a fundamental Proclamation and maybe the
most you know what's the proclamation
human beings are created in two forms
and that's something that of course
we're questioning like Matt at the
moment
no to our great Chagrin because it might
be the most fundamental perceptual Axiom
you know the distinction between the
Sexes and the second one is that men and
women alike are created in the image of
God and you know that's quite that's a
ridiculously radical proposition and it
is I I do think it is the right it is
the essence of the uh this the Christian
stance against slavery in particular now
we're going to talk about the French
revolutionaries as well their Tower of
Babel types by the way those they are
totally power battle types yeah so I
mean their their approach is a
fundamentally atheistic one it is to
root out the biblical influence really
any any religious influence and to set
up in its and instead uh the human
reason they said but as you pointed out
what it really becomes is the the rule
of the powerful so once you take out the
biblical insistence on the equality of
all people once you take out the
powerful biblical message that every
person is called to work with God every
person is called to advance God's
purposes every person can have God's
spirit within them right I mean this is
the teaching of the New Testament you
come to Christ he pours his Spirit out
on you doesn't matter if you're a man
woman Jew Gentile slave free once you
take all of that away and it becomes
about oh well you know we're going to
worship human reason well according to
whom right who defines that who's in
control
exactly to what end exactly well yeah
yeah well the um
it's been interesting to me to watch
what's happened with the with the Four
Horsemen of the the four atheist
horsemen over the last few years I mean
Hitchens died so he's obviously off the
table but it's interesting to
consider what's happened to both Dawkins
and and Harris so Harris and I say this
with all due respect I like both those
men and I think that I actually think
they're honest men and I think they're
trying to strive upward I think they're
both wrestling with God in their own way
and I mean that like seriously with all
due respect Dawkins is a real scientist
and I think Harris is a real moral actor
now one of the things that's happened to
Sam is that he's kind of left the
rational Arena altogether like he's
pursuing meditation that that's his
fundamental goal and so Sam has created
for himself a sort of uh what would you
say a disembodied Buddhist deity and I
think the reason that Sam leaves his
deity
inarticulate is because if he made it
articulate he would criticize it to
death with his rationality
and so he leaves he has an ineffable God
and he's now he's decided to devote his
life to that
and so that's interesting you know when
Harris was motivated I talked to Sam Law
Harris was motivated fundamentally by
the problem of evil and he wanted to
ground Morality In something unshakable
and he thought the only thing unshakable
was objective truth but it turns out
that grounding morality and objective
truth actually isn't possible and for
all sorts of technical reasons and I
write about that a little bit in this
new book and so Sam turned to Buddhism
and then with Dawkins like
I think Dawkins has seen and I know I'm
speaking for him but I believe this to
be true in good faith that
the rationalist humanists that he
thought would replace the superstitious
biblical religious types turned out to
be whim governed tyrants
right and so that rationality that
unmoored rationality it seems to
degenerate in two ways very rapidly it
degenerates into something like power
claim that's driven by worship of the
intellect right and Marx is a great
example of that because he was so
intellectually arrogant and that
characterizes universities like Matt and
it's part of the spirit that raises the
Tower of Babel you know because that's
associated with luciferian presumption
and so that worship of the intellect
produces a luciferian Tower of Babel and
that's happening all around us
like at an absolutely mad rate but the
other thing it seems to produce is a
kind of disintegration of narrative into
hedonism
you know and Hedonism is a kind of
polytheism right it's just you just
worship whatever whim happens to seize
you at the moment and so you get a
luciferian presumption on the one part
on hand that produces endless towers of
Babel or you get a degeneration into
kind of mindless Hedonism and our
culture at the moment is well it's
toying real hard with both it's like we
got the worst of 1984 and Brave New
World at the same time
and so the alternative to that is I
think what the biblical Corpus does is
lay out the alternative to that that's
that's its that's what it's striving to
do you know so all right so back to the
French Revolutionary types so so how do
you read what happened in France you
said it was elevation of rationality to
the highest place for example yeah yeah
and I mean rationality is yeah with a
capital R which is really just vignette
begs the question again what's the
substance of that here's my thesis if
you look historically and also sort of
philosophically what the French
Revolution and maybe the enlightenment
writ large and those are separate things
I realize but just mushing them together
for a second what they really do is they
try and take the moral content of the
biblical tradition and then separate it
from the biblical God and biblical
obligation I think and so what they're
really doing is living on borrowed time
right I mean so they're really they're
trying to separate out these fundamental
moral precepts and they're trying to
ground them in something else and it
just doesn't work I mean we've had
centuries of experiment with it right I
mean we've seen it it doesn't work I
mean what the French Revolution quickly
ends up with of course historically is
they're all killing one another because
it becomes purely a power play yeah I
mean it's who's who has the power the
enlightenment types so I'll make their
argument for them and this is a sort of
argument that Pinker would make is no
you're wrong about that Senator Hawley
because we didn't really see any
progress towards the states of being
that characterize the modern State till
we establish the scientific method and
it was the Enlightenment types that
drove that and it was the divorce of
science from the religious underpinnings
that allowed that to occur that escape
from say biblical Superstition and other
forms of superstition allowed for that
Clarity of mind and so but here's what I
think is the problem with that you can
tell me what you think is that I and and
I think you can see this reflected in
the all-out assault on the scientific
front by the leftist rationalists
radicals who are an inheritors of the
French Revolutionary tradition it's like
they're not just going to plow their way
through the religious tradition they're
going to take science out at the same
time because I think true scientists
operate according to religious
presuppositions and they don't recognize
them and and and and I think this is
true just as true of someone like
Dawkins as anyone else so let me lay out
the presuppositions and you tell me if
you can see any holes in this okay so
the first presupposition is that there
is a logos in the cosmos right is that
there's an order in reality itself
okay because otherwise why bother
investigating if it's not and then that
order is comprehensible to the human
spirit
right so not only is there an order but
we can understand the order now these
are axioms right you don't start the
pursuit without accepting these axioms
okay the next Axiom is
if we understood the logos that
understanding would be universally
individually and universally beneficial
it would make you a better person and
communicating what you discovered would
make Society better so not only is there
a logos in the cosmos and not only is
that logos apprehensible but
fundamentally that logos is good in that
it's expanded understanding will be of
universal benefit now not only are those
religious presuppositions because they
cannot be established on scientific
route they have to be accepted before
the Enterprise begins
they're they're also specifically
judeo-christian right and then there's a
there's a third fourth element religious
element which is in order to be a
scientist
you have to conduct yourself in an
ethical manner which is that you have to
allow your investigations into the
intrinsic logos of the world to reshape
your own tyrannical presuppositions
right you have to take your hypotheses
and you have to throw it against the
world and if it doesn't withstand the
contest then you have to be willing to
abandon it and that's also as far as I
can tell that's also a religious Praxis
fundamentally and so
the scientific Endeavor that the
enlightenment types claim is the
precondition for modern flourishing is
actually
inextricably embedded in the biblical
tradition and I think that also explains
why science emerged in Europe and
nowhere else
yes I I think you're right I agree with
that and I think that if you if you play
that out if you look at the
enlightenment tradition and what it
becomes in the 20th century in the late
20th century when we get to critical
theory when we get to the postmodernists
and you're you're hinting at this is
they reject the scientific Enterprise as
you've been describing it almost
completely you know their position then
becomes there is no objective truth
there are only points of view you know
there is no there is no place of
neutrality to stand in the universe
there are only situated persons with
situated points of view there's there's
no such thing as any universal anything
and so we all we can do is describe our
own experiences and that that's best
done on the basis of power relationships
right so the the enlightenment well it's
only done on the base it's not even best
it's that there's no alternative that's
the most nihilistic claim of the radical
post-modernist types is that not only is
it a power game it can't be anything
other than a power game and all claims
to the contrary are just
subtler expressions of a power game God
it's brutal it's a brutal Doctrine that
is it isn't I my argument would be that
is not the enlightenment getting off
track as it were that is where the
enlightenment leads you once you once
you say that the only standard for any
truth the only standard for any reality
is going to be this Cartesian idea that
only what we as humans can hold our own
minds can affirm ourselves can verify
ourselves only what we can control I
really think that the Cartesian
Enlightenment attempt to Define truth
apart from the biblical tradition or any
religious grounding is an attempt to
control it to say if we control the
knowledge then it's real and as it turns
out so that's why it's also and I found
this out when I was investigating the
Tower of Babel story and its association
with luciferian presumption so the it's
this it's the descendants of Cain who
turned to building cities and it's the
descendants of Cain who first build
weapons of war
and also Babylon in particular is
founded by ham and ham is the son of
Noah who laughs at his own father's
nakedness right so that's all tangled up
in the story of the Tower of Babel now
what seems to happen and and I see this
with with modern luciferian intellects
you see this on the engineering front
often like I have a lot of respect for
engineers but they tend to presume that
the proper way forward is a
technological way is that the way you
deal with the fundamental existential
concerns of Life Is by is through
technological mastery
and now it's obvious the case and you
make the case for this in your book that
human productivity including tool
building productivity is admirable but
the question is
like do we worship the tools or do we
worship the ethos that utilizes the
tools and are those separable
and I think the way the the
enlightenment types went wrong is that
they didn't understand that there was an
ethos that made
objective science possible and that that
ethos was encapsulated in a narrative
not in science itself and that
technologists are making the same
problem it's like well we can just solve
this with technology it's like well if
evil people control the tools then the
tools will be used for evil purposes
right and so and so I read this great
book once called uh the wealth of the
wealth and poverty of Nations by a man
named Richard Landis and he analyzed
Japan in particular because he thought
Japan was a very interesting case
history the Japanese have a very
disciplined culture
and after World War II it was a
westernized culture and Japan is very
very wealthy
Japan has no natural resources
so then you might say well what's the
basis of Japanese wealth and the answer
is something like well it's an ethos
the Japanese are very disciplined and
the fundamental transaction between two
Japanese is honest
a guy think you could say that there
isn't any other natural resource except
air or maybe you know there we breathe
the only natural resource is Trust
trust is predicated on like you can't
trust productively unless people are
honest
and if people are honest and trustworthy
then they can cooperate in a manner that
makes
abundance
not only possible but inevitable
and
that means that the technology has to be
embedded in an ethos and that ethos has
to facilitate trust and so
the way that you make a society Rich
isn't as a consequence of
them being blessed with natural
resources say or even with technological
prowess
it's that
all of that's embedded in an ethos and
and that ethos is the one that enables
people to cooperate and compete
productively and generously and that's
the ethos that seems to be laid out in
the biblical Corpus and though that's
the case you're making in your book I
agree and you could just ask yourself
Jordan I mean you think about our
technological advances you think about
AI now but but why is it I mean if if
you look at science alone
my contention would be science alone is
at a loss to explain why those who are
not the most intelligent however you
define it why those who are not the
strongest however you define that why
they should not be privileged in some
way in other words if you look at what
what's the natural world where that is
true right and this is Darwin natural
selection and you had the social
darwiness of the last century who we
rightly despise and condemn now but they
would have said that's just science
we're just applying to the human realm
what we've observed in the natural
scientific realm and why should it be
that to those who have the AI technology
that can displace thousands of workers
why should they not be the ones who have
most power in society I don't know that
science well there's a Russia to us well
there's a rationality there like I think
the rational stance is that if I can
take what you have then why shouldn't I
yes like why isn't that a rational
stance in fact right the Romans would
have thought that was a rational
absolutely and the Greeks would have
thought that was a rational stance man I
would say it's partly because it does
have its own self-evidence if you're
weak and Despicable and I can just take
what you have and there's nothing you
can do to stop me why isn't it the case
that your own contemptible weakness
isn't evidence that I should be allowed
to do whatever I want with you
that is not irrational now that doesn't
mean it's not wrong
and so now I would dispute you know I
would dispute to some degree if you
don't mind momentarily the the the the
social Darwin
are are a darwinist argument you know
because I I talked a lot to friends to
wall the primatologist and you know
dewal has shown quite clearly that among
chimpanzees who do have quite a
patriarchal social structure and who are
extraordinarily powerful physically and
brutal beyond belief like they hunt call
of us monkeys those things weigh 38
pounds and they eat them when they're
alive
right there's no pity in chimps
and so the chimps will tear each other
apart and they do that in their chimp
War but dewal has shown very clearly in
his analysis of The Chimps that he's
studied over the last 20 years that the
biggest roughest toughest social Darwin
Triumph male is very very likely to meet
an unbelievably violent and and to rule
very briefly over a very unstable and
malfunctioning Community he showed that
the the stable alpha males sometimes
they're the smallest male in The Troop
they're the most reciprocal
individuals in the entire troop male or
female they do the best at tracking
social relationships and engaging in
essentially reciprocal altruism
and so that's the state That's the basis
for a stable polity even among
chimpanzees
so it's another bit of evidence but this
time from the scientific side that power
it doesn't look like in a biological
community or in many biological
communities that it's power and
dominance per se that are associated
with uh let's say biological success
reproductive success
so you know there are situations baboons
are more baboons are more violent but
even then it's it's no by no means as
simple as the most powerful male is the
one who propagates his genes forward and
it's certainly not the case in complex
social organizations not true with rats
for example yes
well it may be on the just on the on the
social darwiness point that we could say
the social darwinists were crude
scientists you know they they didn't
make their argument as they might have
they didn't understand the science but I
would still press the point Jordan that
even then even in these and these other
species that we observe do we observe
these species sacrificing their lives
for one another do we observe them
carrying on the kind of moral
interactions that we say that's
praiseworthy we know where where someone
a stranger will give his life for
someone else where they will put
themselves in danger in order to protect
people they don't really even know we
look at those things and say that's
praiseworthy you see the rudiments of it
you know just like you see the rudiments
of language you you can see it starting
to emerge even from the bottom up
so so you see it among rats for example
so I'll tell you a very quick story you
may have heard me tell it before but
Jacques have established this with rats
and it's a killer it's a killer
observation I think it was Nobel Prize
worthy so if you pair two male juvenile
rats together if one of them has a 10
weight Advantage he can beat the other
one in a wrestling bout and rats like to
wrestle
and it's easy if you watch rats wrestle
once to assume that it's a form of
dominance and that the big rat wins the
big powerful rat wins 10 weight
Advantage will do it
and so you could imagine that's a
scientific observation you pair two
juveniles together they wrestle the big
rot pins the small route the big rat is
now dominant he's the Victor and that
you know has implications for his
potential reproductive success in the
future but thanks
this is such a crucial move
he realized that rats lived in Social
organizations and that they didn't play
once they played repeatedly and someone
you play repeatedly with is a friend
right because otherwise they won't play
with you repeatedly so what banks have
showed was that if you take the rats
again if you put them together again the
little rat who lost has to ask the big
rat to play that's now his rule so he
has to do the play invitation you know
that mammals engage in then the big
Rattle play
and playing is isn't aggression like
almost all mammals can distinguish
between play aggression and genuine
aggression they are not the same thing
at all and you know that if you have a
dog or a child for that matter if you
have any sense at all you can tell the
difference it's like the definition of
sense that you can tell the difference
between play and aggression anyways
if the routes are paired together
repeatedly
and the big rat doesn't let the little
rat win at least 40 percent of the time
might be 30. some significant proportion
of the time the little rattles stopped
playing
and so you have an emergent ethos of
reciprocal play that's a consequence of
repeated matchings right and that's the
same idea in some sense that you have to
play with your future self and that you
have to play with other people is that
you can think this is a this is the
optimistic Union of the scientific
Enterprise let's say in the moral
Enterprise is that there might be an
implicit ethos in complex social
organizations that's a consequence of
what would you call the necessary
constraints that emerge if you have to
repeatedly interact with someone
right you have to treat them like well
what maybe you have to treat them like
they're of fundamental worth and animals
can do that to some degree like The
Chimps chimps have decades-long
friendships
you know and they will they will go out
of their way for each other they're not
that good at sharing food like there's
limits you know like serious limits but
you can see the glimmerings even among
our non-human
um uh cousins let's say you can say GLI
you can see glimmerings of a more of a
deeper ethos
yes yes and and that makes sense and I
suppose that the the way that the uh the
biblical tradition might capture that is
something like natural law you might say
that there is a there's a natural order
to the universe and you begin you see it
you see glimmerings to use your word you
see glimmerings in other species and so
on but my my my point is that I I think
I still hold to is that you it is
difficult to derive from merely
observations of biology or science alone
a moral code of the kind that we live by
and say is praiseworthy and my point in
that is is that this is where I think
there's a certain arrogance to the
enlightenment tradition that will ground
it all on science we'll do away with
religion particularly biblical religion
we'll get rid of all of that we'll
ground it all in science and then we'll
all be better you know I think the 20th
century and no one has has written about
this more than you the 20th century I
think is in many ways a refutation of
that where did we do better uh in this
Century of Science and Technology
I don't I don't think that we did I
don't think we did
no and and you know the The Atheist
types that I debated with one of those
questions that always annoyed them was
well you know was were Marx and Stalin
and Mao humanists
well no no you know they they don't
count it's like well I think they count
they actually count and and it's not
like communism wasn't rational you
accept a few axioms like to each
according to his need from each
according to his ability which sounds
self-evident and rational
you accept that and the whole bloody
nightmare emerges and sojnitzen did a
very good job of of delineating that
like the Communist catastrophe was not
an aberration from an ideal it was the
manifestation of the implicit nature of
the ideal it was the genuine article
which is why it did the same thing
wherever it was implemented you know
that isn't real communism it's like yeah
afraid so after the 20th experiment we
can pretty much establish that you know
and I think the presumption on the
scientific side might not be something
that's
pathologically embedded within science
itself because science itself properly
conducted is really an exercise in
continual humility I think where the
scientists go wrong often is they say
well we know enough right now as
scientists which means our theories to
to be able to say what constitutes
appropriate morality
and and that's you know in in a kind of
by Fiat sense that's what the social
darwinists did
and it was it was premature closure in
the scientific Enterprise
instead of being instead of staying
grounded in ignorance
yes and I and I think this is there's a
reason also that you made this point a
minute ago I think that science as we
know it emerges out of societies
grounded in the biblical tradition
because of the of the fundamental
presuppositions that the world is an
orderly Place uh that we can in fact
discover some of the order of that world
and it will be good for us I mean those
are very biblical Notions you contrast
that with the ancient Epicurean physics
right what were epicurus physics I mean
a scientific turn of mine epicurus had
but he thought that that the world was
composed of atoms right he got that
right he was the first one to see that
that we know of but he thought it was a
fundamentally random place a
fundamentally rent the atoms moved and
fundamentally random ways therefore the
universe was fundamentally random now
when we come to the modern scientific
world and the birth of modern science
then the 16th 17th 18th centuries it
doesn't take the Epicurean Foundation as
its premise no no it takes the then you
made this point it takes the biblical
Foundation then actually no there's
order in the world and we can discover
that and and we can use that to our good
and that would be a good thing and by
the way I agree with all of that but it
has to be grounded in that larger ethic
I think yeah well you know one of the
things the postmodernists got right
and they really did get this right was
that
our Enterprises
are interpretive Enterprise and the
Enterprise that governs our actions is
embedded in a narrative tradition
the postmodernists got that right now
what they got wrong was that the right
narrative is either fragmented so
there's no metanarrative or it's one of
power and that's where they made their
alignment with the marxists for their
own devious reasons and produced a kind
of hyper Marxism where it's not just
economic exploitation that characterizes
economic history but exploitation of all
types across all binary axes for all
social relationships so it isn't that
the what we have on the woke side is
Marxism precisely or even neo-marxism
it's hyper Marxism
right it's it's Marxism raised raised to
an exponent so that every every human
relationship becomes nothing but a
manifestation of power and and that's a
meta-narrative too right and so and and
but it's not a very it's certainly not a
uniting Marinette Maryland narrative
it's a tyrannical meta-narrative and and
it's also incorrect it doesn't work for
chimpanzees and Psychopaths by the way
use nothing but power and Psychopaths
despite what people think tend to be
very unsuccessful partly because other
people catch on and
you know ham the man very rapidly cycle
that's why you have the wandering
psychopath as a kind of narrative Trope
you know the the guy who's who's
hitching a ride from one place to
another The Drifter the drifting loner
well he's drifting because people figure
out what he's up to and then they won't
have anything to do with him so he has
to go find a new population to exploit
you know and online this is something
for legislators to consider you know I
really believe this
I think that all the restraints off the
psychopathic narcissist types all of the
restraints have been lifted online all
of them and in fact their behavior is
facilitated rather than inhibited and if
it's the case that the parasitical and
predatory Psychopathic narcissist types
are a permanent existential threat which
I think is the case biologically and
historically we've disinhibited them
with our technology
that's a very bad idea you know when you
talked a little bit in your book about
pornography you know this is a cool
thing the other thing I found out
when I was investigating this Tower of
Babel story so Babel is associated with
Babylon
and Babylon is associated with
luciferian intellectual presumption and
a kind of technocratic worship but it's
also associated with the horror of
Babylon
right and so there's an idea it's a very
interesting idea that the worship of the
intellect
the raising of tech of the technological
Spirit to the highest place the attempt
to build edifices that compete on the
spiritual side with what's properly
Transcendent also disinhibit feminine
sexuality and pathologize it
and 25 about 25 to 35 percent of
Internet Trend traffic is pornographic
you detailed out what your understanding
of what pornography is doing on the
masculine front so maybe we could delve
into that momentarily yeah absolutely
well if you just look at the data on
this Jordan I mean the the consumption
of pornography of course is as you would
expect given its availability everywhere
is it's just off the charts you know I
mean one researcher equipped and it's
absolutely true that a young man today
can see uh more naked women in five
minutes than his or back probably 90
seconds then his grandfather could in a
lifetime you know I mean so that's
technology has made that available and
as you might expect I mean given the
dopamine effects here the more porn men
watch especially young men the more porn
they want to watch and then you ask well
what what happens over time and what the
data there's an increasing body of data
on this and what it shows is is that you
spend more time on screens you spend
less time in real human relationships so
it massive porn consumption tends to
inhibit dating it tends to inhibit
healthy self-image for men it tends to
inhibit confidence actually it's just
the reverse of what the porn industry I
think would sell right they would sell
that hey you know it this is a this is a
sign of of machismo I mean this is a
sign of your your real man it's actually
porn consumption particularly at scale
makes men more timid weak and more
passive yes less confident and
ultimately impotent well it's also yeah
you know that might be true
psychologically as well as
physiologically because another thing
you document in your book and I'll just
read some stats here that I think are
dead relevant in 2015 so that's eight
it's eight years ago so these are
outdated stats already and it's worse
now one quarter of men of working age
have no job whatsoever
and have done no work at all within the
last 12 months so that's 25 so that's
cataclysmic
in 1970 two-thirds of men made more than
their fathers in in 2014 it was 40
percent
it's manner acquiring 70 percent of all
D's and F's given in grade school only
20 are proficient in writing by grade
eight 24 reading men aren't trying
they're now less than 40 percent of
college students
so between 2015 and 2022
men were 70 of the 1.5 million person
drop in college enrollment and that was
replaced primarily by screen time video
games and porn suicide increases up 25
between 2000 and 2017 and drug overdose
up 250 percent and the majority of
babies by the way now are born in
fatherless homes and so so there's a
weird entanglement there too eh because
one of the
I believe this to be the case is that
one of the motivating factors that drive
men out into the workplace is the
possibility of attaining genuine status
in the workplace as a consequence of
competent Endeavor and that does make
them more attractive to women now maybe
being more attractive to women is I
don't know what percentage it is of male
motivation on the work front it might be
50 percent
you know like I noticed for example I
used to work with high-end lawyers both
male and female
and the males were always competing to
see what their bonus was going to be at
the end of the year
and it wasn't because they wanted the
money I mean they wanted the money you
know but they already had lots of money
they could always do already do what
they wanted on the monetary front it was
a contest
and they wanted to be on top and we know
that the biggest predictor of male
attractiveness to females is
socioeconomic status it's correlated at
with male reproductive success access to
women let's say at about point seven
point six point seven which is a
walloping correlation you don't see like
that in anywhere else in the social
sciences so then you think if you
deprive men of their fundamental sexual
impulse you deprive them of the
necessity of sexual Pursuit maybe you
emasculate them self you emasculate them
almost completely on the Practical front
as well like we have no idea right but
it's certainly possible
it's certainly possible it's certainly
possible and the growing body of
research would suggest that there
absolutely is a correlation there I mean
and you also yeah well and you add to
that the other factors you detail out in
the book so
so the overt demoralization of young men
right so their play preferences are are
stymied in in elementary school they're
taught non-stop from the time they enter
school that the entire masculine
Enterprises oppressively patriarchal and
evil in its Essence derived as it is
from Power
even the American Psychological
Association apparently agrees with that
now their idiot report on so-called
toxic masculinity and then if the boys
do Escape that which they don't then you
have the bloody environmentalist Planet
worshiping Gaia uh sacrificers saying
well you know if you do have any
ambition all you're doing is using it to
rape the planet to our all our eventual
demise it's no bloody wonder the boys
drop out if that's the story that's
being told them
yes exactly and that is the story and
it's interesting George when you put all
that together you've got the modern left
who who feeds Force feeds this to young
men but then when they get older to come
back to screens and porn the the left
also tells them though spend your time
on screens and porn that's fine in fact
anytime you mention porn I've noticed
the left absolutely melts down if you
criticize even slightly porn consumption
the leftist has a fit and says that's
moralistic it's puritanical and I think
the message to men really is when you've
taken the aggregate you're terrible your
ambition is toxic your assertiveness
makes the world a worse place so be
passive go sit in front of a screen
consume some stuff entertain some stuff
and be androgynous that's the message
that they send to men and it is
debilitating in every respect yeah well
I think the conservative type should
take the that accusation of moralistic
and puritanical as a compliment in under
today's conditions and stop being
defensive about it it's like you mean
more or less stick and puritanical in
comparison to your absolutely whim
ridden narrow self-centered
self-satisfied hedonistic moralizing
apocalypse like you mean puritanical in
relationship to that yeah I think if
that's what puritanical means I'll go
with Puritans thank you very much
because what the hell do you have to
offer yeah it's really it's really it's
unbelievably destructively pathetic and
this is also why I think the left the
radicals in particular don't have a
moral leg to stand on you know because I
think and this is especially true for
people like Foucault Foucault was really
really smart like his book The Order of
Things is a real work of Genius
especially the first half he needed an
editor in the second half but the first
half is quite brilliant he was super
smart but as far as I can tell reading
Foucault every single thing he put his
intellect to was an attempt to justify
his his essential perversion his desire
to utilize his sexual behavior in
whatever manner he saw fit regardless of
the cost to anyone children or other men
because he was notoriously promiscuous
after he knew he had AIDS you know and
that was and that was just one of his
many sins I see in Foucault the perfect
example of someone who subordinated his
intellect which he was very proud of to
nothing but the whims of his sexual
drive and that was his God priapus was
Foucault's God kind of a satanic priapus
you know and so and I see that on the
left it's like well why why are you
opposed to traditional masculinity well
it's because it's oppressive it's like
yeah maybe maybe it's because if you
accepted the doctrines of discipline you
wouldn't be able to gratify every
goddamn women that entered your mind the
second it entered your mind and then
that's the definition of self that's
emerged among the radicals I am what I
am which is by the way what God says to
Moses I am what I am moment to moment
and why do you have no right to
interfere with that because I want to be
allowed to do whatever the hell I want
to whoever I want at any given moment
like with no thought whatsoever even for
my own
preservation you know when I say I think
we see that celebrated we see that ethos
celebrated in Pride season
and it's not fluke that it's called
Pride season
yeah I think you're absolutely right
about this and this is why in the book I
talk about the sort of Epicurean spirit
and my mean by that everything you've
just said which is to make the self God
and by self it is the momentary whim
because there's really no self there
that's right there's no self there
there's no self there it's just whatever
your whim or passion is your desire at
this particular instant and this is why
I think it's this that that ideology is
so disorienting to young people in
particular because as they're trying to
form their identity what they get from
Modern culture the tribunes of modern
culture the Academia entertainment
certainly the left what you get from
them is just great just do what makes
you happy just gratify yourself well how
do I how do I choose my my goals from my
momentary whims they have no answer to
that the left has no answer to that and
so can you just choose the primary whim
right in the moment you know well you
know this is also something where
conservatives I think could take a page
from the more thoughtful leftists
because there's an evil interface there
between the worst of capitalism and the
worst of the woke ethos because if to
the degree that capitalism drives a
Mindless consumerism it can feed exactly
that kind of narcissistic
self-aggrandizing ethos and it certainly
does that
that's right and so yeah yeah and so
yeah and and yeah and so this is where
the right
go ahead well this is I want to yeah
we're in heated agreement I mean this is
where I think some elements of the right
they don't have an alternative because
what they're what they basically present
is a form of capitalistic consumerism
you know their answer is yeah well let's
just you know let's consume more stuff I
mean it's it is the the right to be free
is the right to choose right I mean you
had Milton Friedman and God love him
there's a lot to like in Milton Friedman
but his whole concept of Liberty was
it's basically just personal choice
at any time for anything and you know
and he's such a way to the context of
the market you know markets are the
ultimate expression of Freedom listen I
love free markets but to your point If
all we're saying is as an alternative
just choose what you want just choose
what you want to do take off all
inhibitions uh consume consume consume
there's no substance to that either and
I think young people know that yeah well
and I do think that that's a flaw that's
a flaw of classical economics and you
know that's actually been demonstrated
on the scientific front with trading
games
so you know there's a famous trading
game where you take two people and you
say to one of them they're Partners now
you say okay I'm gonna give you a
hundred dollars and you have to offer
your partner some fraction of that and
if your partner refuses neither of you
get anything
it's like what are you going to offer
and so now the classical economic
presumption is that the person making
the offer whose maximum maximizing their
rational self-interest
should offer their partner a dollar
because then they get 99 right the the
first person and the classical Economist
also says because the recipient is
maximizing their rational self-interest
they should accept the bloody dollar
because well you want nothing or do you
want a dollar
but that isn't how it plays out in the
real world not not at all
what happens is that cross-culturally
people offer something approximating 50
percent
and if they don't it's rejected and then
you might say well that's only true in
Western countries because you know it
doesn't really matter to a Westerner one
way or another whether he gets forty
dollars let's say or or one dollar he's
willing to stand on principle but if you
tested that among poor people they'd
take the damn dollar and the reverse is
true actually the poorer you are the
more likely you are to tell someone to
go to hell if they don't give you a fair
deal
and you know that's reflective of this
iterative ethos is the reason that
people insist upon being treated fairly
in a trade is because life is not a
trade it's a sequence of iterating
traits
and the rules that govern the sequence
of an of iterating trade aren't the same
as the rules that govern one trait
because you can screw someone if you
trade with them once and maybe you could
even argue that you should you know I
don't think you should but you could
make that case you know if it's if it's
you or me and in one off why can't I why
shouldn't I just maximize my local
Advantage the answer is I shouldn't
trade my I shouldn't train myself to
think that way that's the answer but
it's another example it's the same thing
with the rats right and the chimpanzees
is that if you have to iterate your
interactions a new ethos emerges and so
the classical economists on the free
trade side the free market side they're
actually wrong in their presumption
about what constitutes the ethic that's
properly associated with
sophisticated long-term trade it's not
maximization of rational self-interest
certainly not in the short term that's
wrong and that's just as wrong as the
post-modern notion that power and
governs everything and when you put
those two things together you get
something seriously toxic you know
there's nothing more toxic than woke
capitalism
exactly which is what we have now yep
that's exactly right or or neoliberalism
I mean Jordan which is really basically
the same thing I mean you've got which
is I'm afraid to say for large segments
of the right the American right I mean
they're basically neoliberals I mean
they they believe in in markets globally
no matter what uh markets without any
any regard to what does it do to Human
Relationships what does it do uh to to
uh the family what does it do to our
sense of of right and wrong and you know
it is a it becomes this this form of of
uh frankly a kind of elitism where you
have the elites who win those who win
and Profit the most from the global
markets and then you've got everybody
else and we're all just supposed to
accept that and I just think uh that's
yeah well that's another Tower well it's
another Tower of Babel yeah well you
know even in games you see this so
there's two ethos that I don't know what
the plural of ethos is actually two
ethosis that operate when you're playing
a game and one is that you try to win
the game
but the other is that you conduct
yourself while you're trying to win in a
manner that makes other people want to
play another game with you oh yeah right
right which is what you tell people when
you tell them to be good sports that's
what you're doing when you're being a
coach or a mentor right you're saying
well don't subordinate the short-term
game
don't subordinate the long-term game
to the short-term game
you know don't don't be too triumphant
when you win don't be too upset when you
lose a given game because you're playing
the long game and there's something in
the narrow even classic British
liberalism that's associated with the
free market that reduces choice to whim
and that reduces trade to local victory
and there's something about that that's
that isn't well that isn't kosher so to
speak you know and it's interesting too
because the British liberals in
particular you can see that if in their
original writings is that they may
basically make a case that something
like
well if everyone is abiding by a deep
religious ethic then we can act as if
people are autonomous individuals
exercising their free choice
and they can take that if for granted at
some point because that ethos ruled but
when that degenerates it isn't obvious
at all that that Pure untrammeled
Freedom of Choice it looks like it
degenerates into something like
consumerist whim
yes and you can see this with Adam Smith
I mean which to your point I think is
that if you look at his uh his theory of
capitalism The Wealth of Nations if you
look at his theory of moral sentiments
which I think he actually wrote
beforehand you can see that it's
embedded in a particular social context
which is frankly very biblically
informed and when you divorce it from
that context you get something that I
suspect he would not have approved of he
would have said wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait no no no no that's not
what I'm talking about so I I think that
that's where we are with with much of I
am not a laissez-faire conservative I
never have been and in my party that's
heretical to say that you know you don't
believe in laissez-faire but I just you
know I am not because I think that it it
does not capture these deeper intuitions
that you've been talking about and it
does not preserve the most important
things in life and in the nation you
know a nation is not a corporation a
nation is not premised on pursuit of
profit you know I have nothing against
pursuit of profit in the business realm
that's great but that's not what a
nation is you know a nation is held
together by Mutual bonds of belonging a
shared sense of purpose and moral Vision
that's what a nation is and we've gotta
we have to preserve that tend that and
and cultivate it if we don't we end up
where we are now which is at daggers
drawn well and you your your your sense
of Nation on the masculine side
you you lay out in your chapters five
through ten
various roles that men can play and and
then you
decorate or illustrate each role with a
traditional story biblical story
generally and then with a set of
personal stories an attempt to extract
out the moral and that seems to be quite
an effective way of communicating and so
you could say a nation is also if it's
going to survive is an Enterprise that
inculcates a set of Virtues in its men
and this has always been a problem
anthropologically right it's been well
known in the anthropological literature
this is why so many cultures concentrate
more on male initiation than on females
right nature initiates females
nature initiates females culture has to
initiate men and so men can go very
can Ascend to the heights but they can
descend to the depths as well and men
who aren't disciplined descend to the
depths very rapidly and that's very bad
for men and it's very bad for women and
it's very bad for the nation and so the
nation has to inculcate Virtue that's
part of its function and you lay out
some rules for men you say well husband
that's a role of responsibility and
opportunity and you do make a case that
well the reason we get married
is because all things considered we
think that it's better to be with
someone than not
you're happy or you're more productive
you're more generous you're a better
person but you're also more resilient in
the face of catastrophe if there's not
just one of you okay so that seems
reasonable father
well why bother well partly because it's
your responsibility let's say but partly
because if you don't bother
well you're missing out one of the Great
Adventures of your life there isn't a
better relationship that you can have
than with your children if you're if
you're wise and careful and to abandon
your children it's so pathetic this this
uh this culture of
random and careless impregnation
so unbelievably pathetic that people who
do who engage in it should just be
shunned it's appalling it's terrible for
the kids but it's terrible for the men
too they're not men
you know they're Psychopathic
manipulators and you know there's the
data on that's quite clear
if you look at the dark tetrad types so
they're Psychopathic narcissistic
Machiavellian and sadistic
they prefer short-term mating strategies
right right so this isn't hypothetical
it's like if you take the worst people
they're the ones who want to engage in
exploitative sexual relationships and it
isn't because they want to be free it's
because they want to do exactly what
they want to do to whoever they want to
do it to right now right and then they
they cloak that up in well you know
sexual Freedom it's like yeah I know
what you mean by sexual freedom
you mean exactly what you want when you
want it
that's what you mean
so okay so so you're the rules husband
father Warrior right that's keeper and
protector let's say Builder
priest and King and your vision in the
book that you're outlining is like the
integration across all of those
so one of the things I've suggested to
my audience of young men is that you're
going to be looking at some point in
your life when the chips are down and
the storms are rising you're going to be
looking for something like a sustaining
meaning and if you don't have it God
help you in those situations and they're
definitely coming in fact you might be
living chronically that way right now
right depressed anxious nihilistic on
the edge of suicide was why because you
haven't adopted any meaningful
responsibility
that's not the actual answer you know
and conservatives have the option now
the the opportunity to put that case
forward say look The Emptiness in your
life isn't because you don't have enough
rights you have all the rights there are
you have more than you should and isn't
because you lack consumerist options
you have Amazon and pornography man
you can get whatever you want whenever
you want it and if that's still not
working
well what are you missing well maybe
you're missing the opposite of that a
little bit of restraint a little bit of
sacrifice some responsibility
yes yes exactly and and I think this is
the part about Vision calling young men
all men but to have a sense of what is
the vision that's going to sustain you
in those hard times you know I and the
book I'd talk about uh some hard times
in my life I mean they talk about losing
my wife and I lost our first baby we
talk about that I talk about losing my
best friend when I was still a young man
to Suicide uh and the point of that is
Jake is it's get correct exactly exactly
I mean we're the same age knew each
other from the time we were 14 he was my
you know my my best friend my best buddy
in life and uh a guy no I lost a friend
just like that
I I had a friend just like that you know
and he swallowed that toxic masculinity
line a little bit different than Jake my
friend his name was Rob dernen my friend
he commanded suicide when he was 40. he
was tall good looking super smart guy
very Charming very witty
um artistically talented uh not
particularly athletic he was he tilted
more to the engineering and aesthetic
side of things but he right from an
early age you know he believed that the
masculine virtues were fundamentally
destructive he adopted a kind of
nihilistic Buddhism and it just did him
in like I just watched him take himself
apart for like 27 years it was ugly he
wouldn't even defend himself in fist
fights in Alberta you know now and then
he lived in a town called High River and
the native kids used to pound on him
because there is a fair bit of
antagonism between the native kids and
the Caucasian kids let's say in these
Northern Alberta towns and uh
and the native kids were rough you know
they could be rough and they used to
beat him up and he wouldn't defend
himself because he thought he was a
patriarchal oppressor like even when he
was 13. you know and there were some you
can understand that to some degree there
was some tension there for real reasons
real historical reasons but his attack
was self-abnegation you know and it just
something like that seemed to have
happened to your friend Jake
yeah yeah and I think that in those to
your point in those moments when you
encounter those crises of Life what is
it that's going to guide you it's not
that stuff is available on Amazon that's
not what's going to get you out of bed
in the morning something that's going to
get you out of bed in the morning is a
sense of purpose and vision for your
life and if that to go back to the most
fundamental of the of the biblical
Vision if that purpose is boy my life
can actually transform the world I can
bring order from chaos I can make a
garden in the wilderness what I do now
can last in a meaningful way for who
knows eternity that's a powerful Vision
you know that's something that'll get
you out of bed in the morning and then
when you add that to that I'm a father
I'm a husband people are depending on me
you know I know my own life is that is
what has pulled me through times where
it's like yeah you know things are tough
right now and I think this is what our
modern culture in the left and the
nihilistic left systematically denies to
men
so you know we talked earlier about the
biblical Corpus in relationship to its
historical validity utility right the
West being predicated on the biblical
narrative it makes sense that we have to
understand it and and assess it and
perhaps return to its virtues insofar as
they are virtues but then there's
another issue here too that you pointed
to which is something like well the
truth of the Enterprise
so let's say well is it true that men
should become husbands fathers Warriors
Builders priests and kings in that kind
of biblical tradition
and the answer to that might be well
what happens if they don't
what's the reality of the situation
where men abandon themselves let's say
to chaos or become tyrannical and Hyper
orderly well then you get something
indistinguishable from hell you know you
get the failed State on the chaos side
or you get the Tower of Babel on the
other side and that's there's abdication
of responsibility in the Tower of Babel
too you know the Soviet men people under
totalitarianism they don't
manifest their own destiny don't tell
the truth they don't take their place in
the world and the consequence of that is
that you get hell real quick
and you might say well hell isn't real
it's like you don't know much about
history if you don't think hell is real
and you also don't know much about
history if you can't see the connection
between the abdication of individual
responsibility
and the generation of hell and very
quickly too
so I you know when we're talking about a
reality that transcends the merely
historical
we could point to the pragmatic it's
like well what happens in the absence of
virtue
well you don't get freedom
you know whim pursuing freedom
and even if you did you wouldn't want it
you know one of the perverse things that
happened has happened on the sexual
front is that as we've increased the
varieties of sexual gratification
available we've increased the number of
people dramatically who have no sexual
contact with other human beings at all
and I think it's 30 percent now I think
it's 30 percent of people in Japan under
30 are virgins
it's something like that it's close to
the same in South Korea and there's a
tremendous number of people in the west
young people who've had zero sexual
contact with an actual person in the
last 18 months
so it's so interesting because you get
that surf fight on the consumer side
and it produces Association that's so
complete that it it demolishes the
desire itself
yes yes and and the desire in it that
manifests in a productive way any real
way right I mean so you don't you don't
go on a date you don't get married you
don't have children and then Society
doesn't reproduce itself I mean it's
it's the ultimate sort of death spiral
but no back to your point about what
happens in the absence of these virtues
you know what happens if you don't
cultivate them and you see on a on a
personal front you know you watch your
life fall apart I mean that's what will
happen as every man who's gone down that
path knows right and that's why you talk
to a man who's been through a crisis in
his life and has come out on the other
side stronger what he doesn't say is at
least I've never heard a man say oh I
just decided to completely give up I
decided to stop caring I decided that I
would stop trying to get better no
that's not what they say they what they
say is I found some purpose to live for
I decided to try and and make something
of my life I decided to aim my life at
something you know catastrophe despite
the catastrophe exactly right despite
because catastrophe is going to come as
you say right that that's life
catastrophe is going to come probably
multiple times and the question is
what's going to what's going to compel
us to live through that and of course if
you are a Christian or a Jew and part of
the biblical tradition which you you can
the hope that you have is not only can
this catastrophe not be the end of me
but actually it could it could redown to
my benefit in some strange way because
God will will redeem it in some sense
doesn't mean I enjoy it but it means
that it'll have some purpose well I
would say that the biblical Corpus if
you just look at it anthropologically
and psychologically
strip it of its
metaphysical and religious pretensions
I'm not saying you should do that but
you can do that
I would say at least what it is is as a
millennial long meditation on what
Spirit you invite to inhabit you so that
you can maintain yourself and those
around you through catastrophe that's
this that's the spirit that guides Noah
right I mean this is really how God is
defined in the biblical Corpus the God
God in the no in the story of Noah is
precisely the spirit that enables the
wise to prepare for the storm and
Shepherd themselves and their family
through it say well does God exist it's
like well insofar as the spirit that
enables a man to do that exists
God exists and then you might say well
what sort of reality is that and the
answer to that is well it's the reality
that drowns you unless you abide by it
now I don't know if that's real enough
for you
but it's an interesting definition of
what constitutes real I mean what's most
real might be what's there when the
times are hardest
right that's how you define the reality
of a friendship or or a love affair
that's a different concept than you know
the material is what's real
it's like no what's real is what
sustains you through the worst
catastrophe
and you might say well there's nothing
there it's like well that's one
perspective your catastrophe is going to
be pretty damn Grim if that's your a
priori attitude that nihilism or the
maybe the Hedonism that goes along with
it you're not going to be very well
protected when when the storms rise
you know and and your book is a
meditation on the idea that if you take
up these responsibilities husband father
Warrior Builder priest king if you take
up these responsibilities you develop
this sort of character
or a relationship with the character
that allows you to Prevail when
when the storms rise you know and the
Seas threaten now that seems right to me
and that that points to a truth in the
biblical Corpus let's say that
transcends the mere historical
yes I agree I agree I agree with all of
that and I if I could just add to your
point but this time from the from the
religious Dimension I would just say
that that what the in my reading of the
biblical tradition is it's not that if
you are a follower of God or a follower
of Christ that you will be saved out of
catastrophe
that that that's not what the tradition
says at all that's not what the Bible
says I don't think I mean I I don't read
that anywhere there what it says is is
that your life will have a meaning
Beyond which you can possibly imagine
what it says is you can be part of what
God is doing in the world for eternity
right it so it's not that you won't have
any hardships of Life quite the contrary
Christ was crucified for heaven's sakes
there will be hardships for sure but
they will mean something and your life
will mean something and ultimately it
will mean something for eternity I mean
that is a purpose to live for and this
is why I found that I I know that the
problem of evil of course is a is it
great to Perennial philosophical
question and I'm not diminishing that or
demeaning it in any way but I do think
that there's a certain uh there's a
certain presupposition there to that
question which is almost as if well if
we encounter evil in the world if we
encounter hardship then there must be
something fundamental then that there
must be no God I mean because it's
almost as if we're entitled not to have
hardship or evil in our lives I I don't
that's not a Biblical presupposition at
all and of course we know that's not
reality no well that's why in the story
of job which is like the most blatant
example of that perhaps is God literally
makes a bet with Satan to take job out
you know and you think well what kind of
God is that it's like you wait man
malevolent things are coming for you in
your life and if you don't think that's
reflective of the structure of reality
you're pretty damn naive
you better be ready and you might think
well you know how can it cause most
that's structured like that be justified
it's like well that's your problem
actually like literally that's your
problem
that's the problem you have to solve in
your life and you know the this pathway
of responsibility productive generosity
let's say honest productive generosity
the the biblical Corpus suggests that
that's the best characterization of the
spirit that'll guide you forward
yes yes and if I could just add
something to that I I think that what
the what the Christian New Testament in
particular would say to people is who
are confronting evil in the world saying
oh you know this is terrible there's all
this evil and malevolence of the world
the Christian answer to that is the
biblical answer is you are supposed to
do something about it God has called you
to be part of the answer right so he has
accomplished something on the cross with
Christ The Salvation is available the
death and resurrection of Christ but
then how does that get how does that get
actualized in the world it is through
followers of Christ animated by his
Spirit who can then go out and Proclaim
that message transform lives transform
the world so my point in all of that is
it is a it is a message that is aimed at
hardship and difficulty it says when you
encounter those things in your life
there can be profound meaning there and
in fact you're supposed to be part of
the the story of overcoming Evil part of
the power of overcoming hardship and
malevolence in the world and doing
something about it and I would just say
that you know there's a profound purpose
in that that I can say from personal
experience animates you and and gives
you a vision for your life
yeah well to all the men who are playing
video games and conquering dragons and
having a hell of a time doing that you
might think about what you're doing is
that the reason you find that so
engaging when it's abstract is because
it's the pattern for what should engage
you in in your life and if you're not
engaged in your life it's because you
haven't picked a dragon of sufficient a
sufficient Merit
and I mean that in the most I mean that
in the most uh in the least literal
sense right in some ways because it's
it's a narrative Trope but I also mean
it in the most real sense
is that if you haven't found meaning in
your life it's because you haven't taken
on a big enough burden that's a strange
thing it's a strange thing that that's
true but
I think it is it's the closest to truth
that we have it is true yeah it is true
all right Senator Hawley very nice to
talk to you I understand that in
principle we're going to meet in
Washington in a couple of weeks again
yes sir I can't wait that'll be good
that'll be good we can further our
conversation and for everybody watching
and listening thank you very much for
your time and attention
two such matters they're worth taking to
Heart they're worth that in all possible
ways
um I'm going to talk to Josh Hawley for
another half an hour on the daily wire
plus side of things
um I think we'll talk we're going to
talk in more personal terms I want to
know more about his thoughts about how
to mediate between the political and the
metaphysical because that's a constant
battle for a politician who's attempting
to conduct himself by ethical standards
it's a very very tricky question
technically and practically so I think
that's what we'll delve into on The
Daily wire plus side so give us give
some thought to joining us there
um and uh to the film crew here in Red
Deer Alberta that's where I'm at today
thank you for your help it went very
smoothly into the daily wire plus folks
for facilitating this that's much
appreciated
Senator Hawley thank you very much for
your book and also for talking today and
uh we'll see you soon
see you soon thank you so much for
having me
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com